more on the Trump investigation and the
Trump presidency were joined by Gabriel
DeBenedetti national political reporter
at Politico Gabriel good morning good
morning well let's start with this whole
immunity question and Michael Flynn his
lawyer says he has a story to tell at
least so far the House and Senate don't
seem to be interested in the immunity
offer what do you think is going on here
well he clearly has a story to tell but
basically what he is doing here is
trying to make sure that he's not in in
legal trouble obviously but he is trying
to make clear to people that he is in
the middle of all this and that he's
really the good guy in this situation I
think what we will see now is a lot of
jockeying on that on the hill from the
house and the Senate side to try and
determine whether or not to actually
give him that immunity we need to see
though what exactly what story he's
going to tell because Michael Flynn of
course is at the center of this entire
situation though speaking of those
committees it has been a rocky week for
the chair of the House Intelligence
Committee Devon Nunez he has resisted
calls to recuse himself where do you
think this leaves the house
investigation I know the Senate stepped
in and said we're going to be the adults
in the room here yeah that's exactly
right I think what you're gonna continue
to see at least all signs point to it is
continued divisions between the
Democrats and the Republicans on the
house side the Democrats have
essentially called for Nunez to step
aside they're more or less saying that
he is too partisan too tied to the white
house at this point in that his all his
actions moving forward are not going to
be credible so we're not likely to see
much coming together think he stays on
is the chair of this committee he's
given no no reason to believe that he
will step down from it and none of the
Republicans on the committee are calling
for him to step down but those like Adam
Schiff the Democrat love the top
Democrat on the committee are certainly
saying why are we gonna continue to
cooperate on this yeah practically
speaking how does an investigation go
forward if they don't even trust the
chairman well I think what you might
continue to see is basically two
parallel probes one from the Democrats
have one from the Republicans that's
obviously not ideal so what we saw last
week with the Senate side saying listen
we'll take over from here
were the adults in the room you know
that may be the way that this this goes
from here on out I gave yesterday at the
White House press briefing press
secretary Sean Spicer remained defiant
as to the allegations that Donald Trump
is made by a twitter that the Obama
White House or President Obama somehow
surveilled members of his team he said
this is Sean Spicer that members of mr.
Obama's administration had done quote
very very
bad things is there any proof of that at
this point still no proof of that but
what we are continuing to see is the
White House pushed this line the White
House knows that these briefings in a
way that they've never been before are
now appointment viewing for millions of
people around the country they are
trying to get this message out there
never before has a daily press briefing
been seen like this or been thought of
like this but this is the White House's
message you know regardless of what the
actual evidence on this situation is
meanwhile there is actually a
legislative agenda here that has sort of
been sidelined by this is was the
failure of the effort to repeal
Obamacare how much damage is that done
to the whole idea of tax reform well
it's going to be a really a much bigger
lift because part of the proposal for
Obamacare for the Obamacare repeal was
going to be the baseline using these
baseline numbers for tax reform but even
that even from a political perspective
you know the White House is having a
much harder time dealing with some
Republican members of Congress that
they're going to need on their side for
tax reform not only that they're trying
to win over Democrats but Democrats are
even more hardened in their resistance
to the White House so it's not
impossible but it's a pretty big climb
what's on that note the president
directly took on members of the freedom
caucus via Twitter this week does that
does is their eventual date on there how
does that relationship go in the next
couple weeks given the fact that he
needs them to pass any of his
legislative priorities that's exactly
right I think what you're gonna try and
what you're gonna see is a lot of
backroom stuff where the White House is
going to try and reach out to these
folks but realistically if that doesn't
work you're going to continue to see
ratcheted up emotions on both sides
especially as lawmakers go home to their
districts in the coming weeks and hear
from their actual constituents but the
White House doesn't seem to be backing
off yet in some cases even suggesting
maybe primary challenges are in order
for these high states chicken yeah you
will Gabriel DeBenedetti thanks for
being with us this morning
thank you